How can we create internalized lasting
motivation for every day "should"
behaviors? These are the things people
know they should be doing but just
struggle to muster the motivation to do
on a regular basis. These images give you
examples of the many such behaviors: save for the future, donate to
charity, read to your kids if you're a
parent, eat healthfully, take care of the
environment, vote, don't text while you're
driving, that sort of thing. And they also
represent, by the way, many of the pretty
serious and persistent social and policy
challenges that could be improved pretty
dramatically if we could find scalable
ways, scalable and and low enough cost
that we could afford to scale them, to
get people to change their behavior. Now
I'm not obviously close to the first
person to realize that we need to get
people to change their behavior. These
are just a couple of the
huge number of examples of appeals
people see every day to change their
behavior.
You can exercise. There's medicine. You can
beat diabetes by eating a healthy diet.
we can save the environment by turning
off the lights. One thing I want you to
notice, the main thing I want you to
notice about these, is that these are all
pragmatic appeals, right? They focus on
the self-interested or otherwise
pragmatic reason why people should
change their behavior. And the problem
with that is that's telling the reader
why the person who made the appeal
thinks it's important. Or probably more
accurately, the person who commissioned
the appeal. But the problem
with that is that it it relies on
self-control or willpower to get people
to change their behavior, and
psychologists have known for some time
this is not a domain you want to be
relying on, right? Self-control and
willpower works sometimes in acute
situations. It does not work for
sustained behavior change. And so I've
been thinking a little bit about how to
sort of focus this question even
more and the sort of focused version of the
question that I've been focusing on is:
how can we get people to care about the
things they don't already care about but
should? A couple of things I want you to
sort of keep in mind about "should"
behaviors. One is this doesn't represent
the situation. People know what the
responsible choice is. They're not
in doubt about that, right?
And so telling them or reminding them of
the pragmatic reasons why they should
change their behavior is unlikely to be
giving them new information, so it's not
really clear even what the theory of
change is behind a pragmatic appeal.
Other things that are a little
less directly obvious are our
problems like myopia, or intertemporal
discounting. It's referred to in varying
ways depending on whether you're talking
to a psychologist or an economist. But
the central idea there is that we over
value the immediate present and
undervalue the distant future. And so as
with many "should" behaviors, when a
behavior requires a sacrifice in the
immediate term in service of some
distant pragmatic goal, the distant
pragmatic goal is unlikely to win that
fight. Relatedly but distinct is the
notion of procrastination, which is
simply: even if I do care about that
distant pragmatic goal, there's rarely a
compelling reason for me to start
changing my behavior today rather than
tomorrow, right? And both of these pose
very serious challenges to
getting people to engage in "should"
behaviors. And then the third important
thing to remember, I guess it's the
fourth important thing I want to make
top of mind for you is that positive
impact for many of these behaviors
depends on sustained repeated change in
behavior. And that's really important
because there's been a major and
important movement in behavior change
recently called called "nudge." And most
people refer to it as nudge, and it's the
idea that you can set up choice
environments so that the easiest thing
to do is the thing that's in most
people's best interest.
And it's a huge innovation. I think
it's probably the single most important
innovation in the science of
behavior change, I don't know, maybe ever.
It's a hugely important innovation. But
the problem, the weakness of it is that
it's not very well suited to the sorts
of "should" behaviors that require
sustained change across a wide range of
contexts, for the simple reason that we
don't have control over enough of the
context in which people are making
decisions, right? If you're trying to get
people to adopt healthy diets, you might
be able to change the order of the menu
items at a restaurant, but that's not
going to transform very many people's
lives, because most people don't eat at
one restaurant all the time. And so the
sort of complementary idea to nudge that
I've been working on with my
collaborators is something I'm calling
'values alignment." And the idea is to
identify existing strongly-held and
widely-shared values that the desired
behavior might serve. And then frame
appeals for that behavior in terms of
how they might serve this alternative
value. And so the idea is you're changing
how people think about the reason for
engaging in "should" behaviors. It
becomes less about the distant pragmatic
outcome you're pursuing and more
about living in accordance with some
value that is important to you in the
immediate term. And so the idea here,
sort of from a theoretical perspective, I
talked about intertemporal discounting,
this problem that the distant pragmatic
outcome just isn't a strong enough
motivator for people. the idea of values
alignment is that you replace that
distant pragmatic outcome with an
immediate symbolic outcome: the good
feeling of knowing you're being the kind
of person you feel you should
be being. And when I say "values" I really
do mean values broadly construed, right?
what a person thinks is important in
life. What has immediate motivational force.